I just we were just meeting fans the
whole night so I thought it was oh like
a big fan like your guys show whatever
this guy comes up to me and kisses me on
my ear oh no that's so sensual and then
he walks away and I was just like I
couldn't even believe what the happened
and then bar looked down he's like
[Laughter]
[Music]
why welcome back to another great
episode of care for boys today we have I
have my phone in my hand but I guess
that's a part of the bit now let's
go put this in your hand ready okay
today we have with us nectar hard
szer get yours this one's POG if you
guys are not in the Hawaii you wouldn't
know what this is but passion orange
guava is a beautiful drink a and with us
we have Under the Influence right over
there we got v w and Esther thank you
guys hey I wanted to ask you because I
feel like you grew up uh a bad boy for
some time yeah Bo that was a very
naughty boy with with these two guys
being bad boys themselves I always
thought there was a Oh no wait which one
Barton Joe check out these tats you
think this a bad you actually did spend
time in juvie yeah yeah yeah yeah when I
was 12 I went to juvie for about 6
months 6 months yep yep were you guys
roommates did you grow did you did you
grow up around La uh no so I that was in
Jersey Fort Lee yeah right outside
that's like the part of Jersey close to
New York but yeah I escaped
juie how come you have to go to juvie I
was a bad boy uh did you do what you do
what was your thing that was the ACC
that was the accusation I did not do
that but um I you did I thought you no
no no I didn't not do that that was a
car no I did I I lit I lit many things
on fire you're arsonist he's an arsonist
and then uh there was it was like the in
in prosecution she called me a oneman
crimes spree and then my lawyer was like
he's 12 it was like he's not a man he's
a curious boy yeah he's just he's
growing he's gr what's your preferred
way of starting a the best way I mean I
was just like lighter fluid lighter kind
of guy you know is that what you used at
the massage place wax paper he also was
you l a massage place on no acupunctur
AC yeah sorry acupuncture except I was
like four of the you four years old he
kind of he kind of had you beat dude
what was your choice what was your
choice of no it was so what happened was
U my mom would go and get all this
[__] acupuncture [__] done like a lot
of Asian moms would and then so I'm in
the waiting room I'm kind of bored so I
wander into the other room rooms and in
the other room you know how they'll have
like the bench and they have like the
wax paper that they put over so that
they can rip open and I saw like the
cupping things and then the cotton ball
so I was like oh that's pretty cool so
I'm like let me light the wax paper and
then I'll blow it out so I I light the
wax paper and I go I'm that's pretty
cool so I'll light it again and then
each time I'll try to like drag out how
long
I wait for to blow out he literally play
arsonist chicken like and then so it got
it got to it got to the pillow and then
I was
like I was like [__] so I run into the
waiting room and then I would like be
all slow cuz I don't want to like alert
anyone and you know like the waiting
room like paper cups are like this small
so I get like this
water I run back and I
go and then I went like maybe like 5 10
trips and the whole bench is now on fire
and my mom's like signing to like I got
my therapy done or whatever like Mom
let's [__] go and then a nurse runs
out it's on fire what's
happening find out that it was you I
don't know I have no idea they have to
know it was
you they're watching back to tapes this
kid is just [__] burning down their
[__] bed so unsupervised dude I have
no idea I didn't know you took 5 to 10
trips like a volunteer fireman that
video must be so funny to watch back
though like this kid filling up little
cups of water and it's those cone ass
cups too flimy as [__] dude you know
where it was it was on you know ABC Cafe
it was in that plaz on Garfield damn oh
the one that's all charred and black
still and it has like a burn victim as
the receptionist that one the one with
all the flowers on the [__] telephone
pole outside no no no no no so you so
you're on your record you've got a car
you burnt a person yeah uh the I almost
burnt down a Barnes & Nobles oh had a
com they had a
and it wasn't even like I didn't have
anything against Barnes & Nobles we were
like you're a borders guy yeah borders
paid me to go there they saw me in the
borders parking lot and they're like no
no no go to Barns & Noles but what kid
hasn't got a lighter and Aquin it and
did a flamethrower that's classic that's
classic done it then we're good I was a
[__] as a kid for wa how did you almost
burn down a Barnes so so my friends were
all skaters and like the the underground
parking lot of the Barnes & Nobles was
like a popular area for kids to skate
and then met up with them there and
there was just like the dumpster was
full of like paper for some reason like
giant sheets of paper so you were
[__] and then so like we just grabbed
some of the paper out and started like
lighting it and then it was like and
we're just like with like a group of
12-year-olds you know what I'm saying so
like everyone's just getting more hyped
and then like and then eventually
started to get really big and everyone's
like yo maybe we should try to put it
out I was like no ah and then I went
into the dumpster grabbed like way more
paper threw it on there and then that
was when we were like all right this is
scary and then we tried to we did the
same thing we got like this little
bucket that we found in like a Supply
Closet filled it with water tossed it on
it all it did was create smoke like we
couldn't breathe so we just ran and then
uh when we came back like there was like
every firet truck in the town was like
at this Barn holy [__] did they catch
you guys yeah and then one of my friends
walked in to like go look at it and then
they grabbed his ass cuz I guess they
saw him on the camera and he just
straight up snitched on me he like it
was that guy he's over there damn and
then I got arrested right there is he
white he was a white boy we don't [__]
with him no more but yeah he's dead now
they can't wait to tell on you they
haven't found him in weeks there's
flowers outside his house so your juvie
charges were all the things you ever set
on fire they like collected it all it
was a lot of stuff it was like I built
the case on his guy got the red yarn
[__]
everywhere it was like a lot of uh I did
I fought a lot as a kid so there was
like
on there vandalism like just a bunch all
the the usug you know wow you really
turned your life around how many fights
did you win most of them at 12 yeah but
then I went to juvie and I started
losing a
lot those kids are bigger yeah they're
like 16 17 they've been fighting forever
I'm was like damn I'm 12 so you only
ever got in trouble as a minor you never
you don't got nothing on your actual no
not as an adult I mean I'm the opposite
he was like a good boy and then as soon
as he became an adult I know that you
had you got in trouble for the what
happened at the protest that's what blew
me up that's the thing where your mug
shot went out and everybody found out
about youuh before that I was just a
terror to society oh oh fill me in on
the protest what happened yeah tell them
the story about that what happened what
happened um so the the whole protest
thing was I mean despite despite
everything I've done like I I like to
think that my heart's always been in a
good place so I was out there trying to
like fight for change and then uh I was
already on probation for an assault
charge so I was just like an easy easy
victim and they uh they locked me up for
some bogus ass charge uh it blew up
because of how like Bogus the charge was
and then um I did a year and a half of
house arrest and then the last week wait
what was the charge we need some details
for the Char ah I'm trying to remember
it it's uh dissemination of police data
so they basically they basically said I
I tried to
like disclos like confidential police
information explain like the piece of
paper thing oh it was a a piece of the
piece of paper was like it had pictures
of like in in De Mo Iowa where I'm from
it had pictures of everybody that was
like protesting so I I literally showed
it to to a news station with like a mask
on I was like these are the people they
want to arrest like if if you if they go
to jail you know why holy [__] I went
home and the next day I was in the
shower actually and then uh butt ass
naked and I had three four four cops
come in with guns they [__] SWAT
swatted
dick hanging out yeah dick dick all out
they they put me in cuffs still naked I
was like can I can I at least dress
myself they're like no we'll do it for
you so I there's a video out there of
them walking me to the to the squad car
and butt naked yeah no you get to pick
the underwear I no I had no underwear on
it was a pair of sweats and a Derrick
Rose Jersey and my arms weren't even out
of the Jersey that's a good Jersey to
wear though that's cool
yeah that's my my whole claim to Fame
but before that I had a couple assault
charges and uh some other [__] were you
wearing like the mask on TV but you had
like all your neck tattoos exposed yeah
that's cool but how did that so that mug
shot when it went out who saw it how did
it get out to the public stuff it blew
up politically like New York Post uh
there's just there was hella articles
about it apparently they were playing it
in like China and Taiwan Vietnam so all
my family members still in Vietnam were
calling my mom like what the [__] is
going on and then Tik Tok got a hold of
it and
uh kind of sexualized it yeah they just
thought I was H the bat boy how how come
you like assaulting so much what's your
favorite way to do it um what's your
favorite part about assult i i i how do
you choose your victim how' you find
your passion no it was it was mostly
just I when when I was a teenager so I
ran away from home when I was 17 I had a
pretty rough childhood so I was stuck in
the mindset of like I have to prove that
I'm a man like I have to prove it to the
world and I have to prove it to myself
so any sign of like disrespect or
whatever like if I feel like you did me
wrong I have to up it like it's not an
eye for an eye it's like an eye for your
life so I was acting you must be
Vietnamese me man that's the old school
Johnny Chang school of thought yeah
Johnny Chang is the homie too yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah for sure church
every week yeah I saw that that's really
cool uh uh the first first dude was like
he [__] my ex and then he shook my
hand after so I I told that made me mad
dude he shook your hand after he shook
my he looked me in the eyes and shook my
hand but did you know that at that
moment that at the time he shook my hand
no I found out 4 hours later so 4 hours
later I dm'd him and I'm like the next
time I see you I'm going to kill you so
I tried to kill him was on Bish mode
damn you put on Bish mode yeah no no no
well at least you commit to your work
he's on vanish
mode but yeah so uh they uh I I almost
did 10 years for that and I was oh
because it got charged as attempted
murder uh they gave me willful injury
how did you how did you try to kill him
was your I had a I had a wine bottle it
was a Barefoot Wine pink moscato bottle
the brand bro shout out I know exactly
what you're talking about shout out
Barefoot yeah so I just uh I just I just
slammed him on the head a couple times
and then he ran out and he got some
stitches this is my first time hearing
this too really I heard that inter no I
don't think he said that in his
interview I said it on online wow does
it last a good amount of whacking does
Hold Up Wait what is the bottle a good
bottle they checking the Integrity of
the murder weapon the the bottle did not
break I feel like I feel like Grey Goose
would be a great
bottle you have to two hand that one the
Kirkland I like her Kirkland doesn't
have like a long enough handle you know
like GRE has a good neck yeah did he
have any like brain damage or something
him he got from what I heard he uh he
got like 20 Staples in his head that has
to be a concussion like that's so
[__] I would have done Amigos so I
could go that's CL I
don't I don't same same same same eating
someone with that is just dinging as you
[__] where's that Ding where's the
[__] ding where's the B damn man and
then what was the second one the second
assault yeah was that like a similar
situation I got jumped so after that I
went back and like so they blame the
victim well no oh okay that would be
[__] up you got jumped and then you
get assault yeah I got jumped I healed
like I drove myself to the hospital I
gave it a few weeks I healed and then I
went back and you could hold anger for a
long time huh I used to yeah this both
times in De Mo de Mo yeah and then I had
a when I was 18 I had a couple gun
charges I feel like when we're like
under 21 though that's when you're the
most craziest absolutely cuz the [__]
that I did back then I I look at I going
that's so
scary I'm almost 40 now and I'm like and
then you see a kid that's 15 and you're
like oh you're a baby and I disapprove
too like I look at my own self I I'm
very disapproving and I feel bad but
you're telling yourself you should be
punished yeah yeah yeah that's like you
have a kid now though yeah that's even
that's even more that's what I'm saying
but at the same time if Tao was doing
similar [__] would you like lowkey give
him like props I get it no I I think I
would really try to like level with them
cuz even now I do you know like Papa you
did it now you're cool wait you're name
is Tiger Tiger no no not like the tiger
tiger sounds better yo can you still
change it though yeah tiger you don't
you don't ever dream to be like a pey
blinders family where all of you guys
are Crooks and [__] and you're living
like a bad well piggy blinders was only
cool cuz those guys went to the war they
never let their little brother Finn get
into it oh but then when he did get into
it they were kind of proud so you're
right yeah okay you going to let him
tell you spoilers like that I I only
watched three episodes oh yes spoiler
alert py bler this far growing growing
up though you didn't have a long life
expectancy for yourself huh you didn't
think long term at all the the night I
turned 21 I uh I actually broke down and
cried cuz I never I I like I was ready
to die at 17 which is why I'd made so
many crazy crazy decisions cuz I truly
at that point in my life I truly did not
care if I lived or not wow so damn um
but you're live and I'm sure you're over
21 and I'm 24 now yeah that's cool man
man and you and you guys is uh you're in
LA and yeah yeah it's a it's a whole
completely different life that I'm very
thankful for yeah yeah yeah what if
someone now like offended you do you
still have that anger like I'm I try not
to but I would I would be lying if I
said
i' if if I'm if I'm the if if I'm sober
I'll most likely walk away yeah uh if
I'm drunk I'll probably fight oh just
cuz I have this inner thing in me that
where I like I would rather die die then
go out as a hoe I I can't allow another
man to hoe me that's
right and how many nights a week are you
drunk
age he's like
seven n n less less now I would say
nowadays
maybe two
three two three really so that mean
somebody walks into you on the streets
they got like a 6040 chance of making it
out but it's also like I can clearly
tell when someone bumps into me and it's
an accident or whatever can also tell
when someone's trying to disrespect you
cuz I'm I'm pretty small I'm pretty
skinny and like people when they're
drunk like to pick on the on the small
guy so it's like I don't like that [__]
has anything happened cuz you guys are
doing a lot of events you do like these
massive meet and greets nothing like
that's ever happened where you had like
a bad situation not to me when you got
harassed oh not not like that but like I
get like sexually harassed that's oh
well that's fine we we're okay with that
I give you a high five while was over
there you know but we don't want to
disrespect you tell us about that tell
us about the time it's a little after
clapping wait we don't want to
disrespect but it's like not you don't
like it right you're not like I mean if
it's a bad [__] I like it but that's
cool oh so she was ugly yeah usually
that's that's the thing that's the
that's when it gets classified as sexual
harassment I feel like is if you're not
attractive no it's it's but he's hella
FY yeah yeah Jason Mamoa fly yeah I know
I have to I'll have to double double
think double double think just pick you
up kiss you on the forehead the
intentions all good it's like all love
that's just sweet though I think we were
we were in Australia doing a tour and
then in the Dance Floor this Indian guy
comes up to me and uh I just we were
just meeting fans the whole night so I
thought it was oh like a big fan like
your guys show whatever this guy comes
up to me and kisses me on my ear oh no
that's so sensual and then he walked
away and I was just like I couldn't even
believe what the [__]
happened John's like
why why am I
hard is that is that that's not an
Indian thing when I kiss go like this
you know like he kisses you and it just
goes away like that he fly he floats
that's not a pass just cuz you're doing
this we could never we could never we
could
never dude that's a pass though if he
fing kisses you goes away like this I'm
like that's a pass but also like what
are you going to do if a GU kisses you
on the ear to beat him up I was even
expecting you're not going to beat him
up are you allowed to by any like frame
of law that makes you even more gay come
on sucks y trying to tell the cop what
happened he kissed me on the air cop's
like what I don't see the problem and
you [__] a dude up cuz he wanted to give
you some gay affection and you're that
homophobic that makes you turbo
gay Dem theide oh God about turbo hope
you're learning
something embrace it dude no we get
drunk we literally kiss our homies oh
this guy wants kiss me unprovoked you
guys have to be drunk for that on the
lips
yeah they like sabotaged me his our boy
our boy was distracting me in
conversation and then he comes up and
just grabs my face that was that was a
that was a
mistake wait what do you mean somebody
else all the other guys you kiss are not
mistakes yeah yeah yeah it was it was uh
it was our it was my birthday dinner
that he threw me it was a surprise
birthday dinner and like we were like it
was some sort of game where it's like
someone DED me to like kiss him on the
cheek or whatever so I had my boy
distracted him I came up I was going to
kiss him on his cheek and then he turned
and I [__] accidentally like that
Naruto scene where it's like s Sasuke
and Naruto kissing accidentally bro
exactly and then your tongue slipped
inide and you're like this kind of
comfortable let just TR yo no eye for
not dude ey for your life he went in
what was weird was he tried to like turn
me to like get my cheek but he like
grabs my face and it was like this like
and I was like what the [__] that's
assault and then like he just walked
away again another assault again I think
Wu talk said like yeah he had he had
mustache hair yeah yeah he had little
little mustache hair and then he was
like it was rubbing on my lip I was like
hell no bro and then later on that night
at 2 a.m. you're like hey we got to
talk hey I've been thinking about that
moment I don't know if it's been on your
mind and nothing like that happens with
you Esther when you guys go out and
everybody's drunk and um I try but they
when I try they say ew you Tred like Get
Away only guy literally exactly how it
goes that's true when a guy and a guy
does it it's okay but when a girl pops
in and she wants to get in on the yeah
you're making it too real you can't do
that but your guys fans are generally
pretty cool they're like pretty polite
they're very respectful yeah they're fun
like we we went out like after Hawaii
like um after our hosting we went to a
different Club district with uh with
some of our fans that were like flew in
from what was it Canada Vancouver yeah
just to chill yeah and they CED a table
and they're like just come to our table
and we're like yes like we pulled up
with them it was fun yeah they're so
cool yeah yeah yeah mhm it's nice to
have good fans like that it's really
cool because if we were to do like a
React channel or something and like we
all had like purple hair we probably
have some [__] ugly ass fans but like
what the [__] really yeah this feels
hella
targeted just shots fire we got dope
fans yeah [__] that's a purple have you
guys done like the like Club tours or
anything like back in the day yeah I
think um we haven't done any like face
to face in like since lockdown and then
we did one meet and greet recently and
then it was pretty cool cuz it was at uh
Juni and Irvine shout outs to our we got
to promote our matcha shop like take it
Bart the best matcha in the world yeah
new and and it was cool because there
was a line and we drove by it and and
then me and bar were like high five
we're not not has beens bro that shit's
[__] sick people are here yeah yeah
they're all there to talk [__] [__] you
Joe B I've been waiting 3 years to say
[__]
you just kidding news careful boys is a
brand just kidding news is the man of
smart people the people of just kidding
news careful boys they are very smart
just kidding news the number one podcast
in the
world
oh